anyway my son is sick so what do I have
to look forward to he's already a little
strange in an awesome way like I haven't
gotten into like boy like Bo yet yeah
have you gotten into that no just a
little tiny touch not so much although
the girls his age aren't smelling so
good yeah well yeah that happens they've
gone there yeah you do have to look
forward to him thinking you are not cool
and be your worst critic so that is
definitely that's already happening well
well done well done you is Advanced yes
exactly yeah he sometimes it's like
every once in a while do something
really cool or if I know someone like I
know like I've met Owen from Jurassic
world and he's like yeah that's like his
favorite now yeah I thought I might be
in once I became an Avenger yeah and
then my son of course not with that well
he can always find the way that I am not
cool like these are high stages I know
he was like Mom why do you have to be
the worst Avenger
[Music]
yeah that helps but then now with
Quantum Mania I've sort of graduated to
being like a senior Avenger and he's
like okay Mom now you're cool yeah I'm
like oh my God
[Music]
[Applause]
all right
[Music]